it was one of the most daring heists in
British criminal history the gang stole
jewelry gold and cash at least 14
million pounds worth and most of it is
still missing the ring leaders were
aging villains who'd already spent many
years in jail they committed the perfect
crime
but what happened afterwards was a
disaster there have been widespread
thefts of precious stones worth hundreds
of thousands to foil the thieves headin
garden now has its own giant strong room
available to every jeweler merchant in
the district the vault was used mostly
by Hatton Garden craftsmen to store
overnight the jewelry they were working
on the gang dressed as builders and
gas-fitters struck on the night before
Good Friday one of them was careful
enough to hide his face from CCTV the
others refer to him as basil he had a
key to the main building and let the
others in through a fire escape door the
gang carried their gear down the fire
escape to the basement courtyard from
the inside basil unbolted the back door
two men climbed the stairs to the second
floor where they brought up and disabled
the lift from the ground floor one or
more of the gang dropped down the lift
shaft to the basement and forced open a
metal shutter they crawled out opened
the unlocked cupboard under the stairs
and disabled the alarm they cut the
power to the outer iron gate and slid it
open they smashed the lock off the
wooden main door and let in the others
they cut through the second iron gate
and drilled through the vault wall
concrete half a meter
the gang raided the vault twice the
first night they set off an alarm that
police didn't respond then a vital tool
broke and they had to leave and buy
another to finish the job
the ringleaders were professional
villains who made amateur mistakes Bryan
Reader 76 kept the clothes he wore on
the raid Terry Perkins 67 gave himself
away when police bugged his car John
Collins 75 used his own vehicle which
set detectives on the gangs trail Danny
Jones 60 gave his own name and address
when he bought a power tool in my view
they were very much analog criminals
operating in a digital world in a letter
to me from jail Danny Jones revealed
that he had offered to show police where
he'd hidden his loot but they had turned
down his offer you would have thought a
place would have jumped with joy but for
some reason which I don't know they are
not they're interested Jones
eventually led detectives to Edmonton
Cemetery in North London under a
gravestone they found two bags of jewels
he didn't tell them he had another
bigger stash nearby what he didn't know
police had already found that one this
part of London is the very heartland of
one of Britain's most notorious crime
organizations in criminal parlance this
is their Manor but were they involved in
the raid the police don't think so but
at least two of the Raiders were
connected to the crime Network and its
name crops up in conversations bugged by
the police 10 million pounds worth of
the stolen loot is still missing so too
is basil the mystery man for the Flying
Squad he's their most wanted suspect
Martin Brunt Sky News Hatton Garden